ROBIN ROSENBERG: Thank you.
My talk today is "Superheroes
and the Life Lessons They
Teach Us." And part of my
mission is that I think the
scientific psychology, we know a
lot of fun facts to know and
tell that can more importantly
improve people's lives
if only they knew.
And even if they knew,
the important thing
is that they remember.
So what I try to do is teach
these little kernels in ways
that are memorable.
And popular culture figures
are great examples.
Superheroes, in particular,
are wonderful examples.
Let me tell you a little bit
about how I got started on
this venture, in this
trajectory, if you will.
I have three sons.
And when the oldest two were in
preschool, they came home
talking about the X-Men.
So I read comics as a kid.
Mostly DC, I have to admit.
And the X-Men was after
my time as a kid.
And so they were coming home
wanting to know about X-Men,
or wanting to watch Saturday
morning cartoons and talking
about X-Men.
And so I bought some
X-Men cartoons,
comic books, and videos.
And I was also writing an
introductory psychology
textbook at the time for
college students.
And I opened up the X-Men
comics, and I was blown away
by how much psychology
there was.
Show of hands, how many people
are familiar with X-Men?
OK, good.
And so that started
me on this path.
So I'll be using a lot
of examples as
you'll be able to see.
I'm going to talk about
hopefully four, but
realistically probably
three lessons.
One is being different
can give you power.
Another is adversity
can be overcome.
And the costume counts.
My mother was right.
And then if we have time, I'll
do superheroes aren't the only
ones with alter-egos.
OK, so being different
can give you power.
Show of hands, how
many people here
grew up feeling different?
How many people grew up
not feeling different?
Wow.
OK, so one person raised
their hand.
It's unusual.
Usually everybody raises
their hand.
So we can talk more
afterwards.
There is a phenomenon in
psychology where human beings
are wired with something called
social categorization.
We're prone to divide the world
into "us" versus "them."
And we are always in "us,"
wherever we are.
"Them," the technical
term is outgroup.
And those people are generally
considered more negatively.
They have more undesirable
attributes.
And outgroup is seen as more
homogeneous than it really is.
So, for instance, vampires,
unless there's something I
don't know going on,
are the outgroup.
And so we view them as
pretty similar--
fangs, suck blood, that
kind of thing.
And we don't generally like
them, at least until recently.
And that's another example
of an outgroup.
That's the 1966 "Batman"
villains.
I mean, they're very colorful.
But we it's all "them."
"Us," the term is the ingroup.
And we consider ourselves
generally more positively.
And we are more likely to help,
trust, and cooperate
with members of our group.
So this is Buffy.
Show of hands, familiar with
"Buffy, the Vampire Slayer"?
OK, great.
So this is her.
And the Scoobies.
And eventually, it includes
vampires.
So the "us" gets wider.
And it's not simply vampires
versus humans.
But it becomes a little
bit more complex.
And the ingroup, everyone has
their own back story.
It's interesting.
That's another us,
DC superheroes.
And so we are prone to divide
the world into "us" versus
"them." And whenever we do, we
amplify the differences.
Blue eyes versus brown eyes--
I don't know how many--
elementary school, there was
this program going
on for kids.
Now being different can
refer to variety
of different qualities.
You can be physically different,
like Nightcrawler,
who is blue and has a tail
and can teleport.
This is a version of the Bat
Girl character, Barbara
Gordon, where her back is
broken by the Joker.
And so she's in a wheelchair.
You can be psychologically
different.
These are five different
psychological dimensions of
personality.
And so people fall on each
of the five lines.
They'll have a point on which
they fall on those dimensions.
And your profile will be unique
because, really, the
points are infinite
on the continuum.
And so you are different.
People at the extremes
are quite different.
But everyone is different,
psychologically,
from someone else.
You can be different by
virtue of having an
unusual personal history.
For instance, Bruce Wayne
witnessed his parents' death.
Hopefully, that is unusual.
But, unfortunately, he's
not the only one
who's experienced that.
So there are a lot of different
ways to be and feel
different within a given
social context.
And I'm going to come
back to the
importance of social context.
So this is normal curve,
the bell curve.
People are undoubtedly
familiar with it.
And we typically think of being
different as being in
the yellow parts, or
maybe part of the
reddish pink parts.
And psychologically, depends on
what you're talking about,
whether being different is
restricted to the tails.
Basically because of the social
categorization "us"
versus "them" phenomenon,
whenever you're feeling
different about something, it
puts you at risk to feel part
of the outgroup when you're
out in the larger world.
So you could be in the blue
normal curve, the biggest
part, the most frequent part
of the bell curve.
But if you're with people who
are in either of the yellow
parts, you will feel different,
even though
statistically you're not.
But that won't matter.
Your psychological experience of
being different is totally
based on your social context.
So if you were really smart, for
instance, and didn't have
a magnet class or a magnet
school, and you were with
other kids who weren't as
smart or gifted in a
particular way, you would
feel different.
But if you had gone to a magnet
school with other
people like you, you wouldn't
feel different.
Everybody with me on that?
How many people here went to
some kind of special school,
magnet school?
Interesting.
So this is the Thing from
the Fantastic Four.
And he is walking through a
glass doorway, which breaks
because he's too big for it.
And he says, "Why must they
build doorways so narrow?"
And the point here is simply
that, again, when he's out in
the social world of everybody
else, all the people in the
blue part of the normal curve,
he feels really different,
which isn't as noticeable
depending
on his social context.
So being different usually
means being part of an
outgroup unless you're fortunate
to be in a place
where there are lots of other
different people like you.
So it's a little bit of a
problem to be different.
And you may have experienced
this.
There's this tension between
wanting to either be or appear
normal, to fit in, to be like
everybody else in your social
context, versus accepting
yourself as you are.
Because if you want to be or
appear normal, there's a part
where you don't like yourself,
which is an
uncomfortable way to be.
So I'm going to show you some
little clips from "X-Men First
Class," which is the prequel to
"X-Men." It's the film in
which they start to realize they
have powers and find each
other and feel a sense
of belonging.
Show of hands, how many people
have seen "X-Men First Class"?
Cool.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-You have no idea what I'd
give to feel normal.
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
ROBIN ROSENBERG: So that the guy
on the right becomes the
character Beast.
He so desperately wants to feel
normal that he injects--
he basically tries out a serum
on himself and ends up
becoming even more mutated.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-You want society to
accept you, but you
can't even accept yourself.
-Should we have to hide?
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
ROBIN ROSENBERG: Should we
have to hide who we are?
So that's one.
People are struggling with this
issue about being different.
This is a clip from "The
Incredibles." Show of hands,
how many people have seen
"The Incredibles"?
OK, so it's a grown-up
cartoon film.
Kids think they understand
it, but they don't.
It's really for adults.
And it's a family.
The superheroes have kind of
gone underground because there
was a lot of bad press
and stuff.
So they are trying to be normal,
be like everyone else.
The older daughter
has a power where
she can become invisible.
So her name is Violet.
And the younger son Dash
is like the Flash.
He can be really fast.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-Normal?
What do you know about normal?
What does anyone in this family
know about normal?
-Now, wait a minute,
young lady.
-We act normal, Mom.
I want to be normal.
The only one normal
is Jack Jack.
And he's--
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
ROBIN ROSENBERG: And
he's a baby.
OK.
And then we have Dash.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-I want to go out for sports.
-Honey, you know why
we can't do that.
-But I promise I'll slow up.
I'll only be the best
by a tiny bit.
-Patience.
-You always say, do your best.
But you don't really mean it.
Why can't I do the best
that I can do?
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
ROBIN ROSENBERG: So it's
the other side.
So in the family, they're
playing out both
sides of this dilemma.
So people in real life and
superheroes find different
solutions to this.
Show of hands, how
many people have
seen the TV show "Heroes"?
OK, first season was great.
But it was really hard to know
where to go with it.
So in the TV show, it's like
X-Men that people have powers
that they develop.
It's a mysterious process.
And one of them can talk to
electronic devices or
electrical devices.
And he doesn't really spread the
word around because people
would think he was
really weird.
So he says-- this is
a cartoon version--
but I keep that a secret.
You never how some people
react to secrets.
So he hides it.
The solution is to pass,
if you will.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
ROBIN ROSENBERG: This is
Mystique, who is, in her
natural state, blue.
Her dilemma is to pass
or not pass.
And in the beginning,
she passes.
Another solution is to
pretend that your
differences are flukes.
This is an early Superboy
cartoon when he lifts a car to
save someone.
And his friends see.
And they're wowed.
And he says, I guess something
happened just for a minute to
give me super strength.
Right?
And people do actually exhibit
super strength when there are
emergencies like this, so OK.
Another solution, which is the
one that I advocate, is to
accept and, if possible,
enjoy being different.
And that when you're by
yourself, or with family and
friends who are supportive,
being different can be a
positive force.
So this is Superboy being alone
and having fun just
exploring his powers, leaping
tall barns in a single bound.
And this is the kid from
"Heroes." And his mom thinks
what he can do is amazing.
And she just thinks he's
the cat's meow.
And loves spending
time with him.
And it really helps him be
comfortable with himself.
This is the Fantastic Four.
And in contrast to when the
Thing is out in public
breaking glass doorways, when
he's with other people who are
sort of like him in that they
got morphed, he can be really
comfortable and be himself
and feel proud and good.
"X-Men First Class," when they
find each other, again, it's
about finding your people,
if you will.
Whoops--and that was "The
Incredibles" when they
acknowledge their differences
and don their tights.
So how can you make being
different work for you?
So superheroes teach us to
recognize and acknowledge the
ways that we're different.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-But Dad always said our powers
were nothing to be
ashamed of.
Our powers made us special.
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
ROBIN ROSENBERG: Thank
you, Dash.
So with recognition, when you
acknowledge and recognize,
comes exploration.
Again, these three little
steps are what
superheroes teach us.
When you realize you're
different, you want to know,
so what does that mean?
What are the parameters
about being different?
How different am I?
So, from the TV show "Heroes,"
this young woman realizes this
she's never been sick.
If she hurts herself, she
gets better right away.
So in exploring, she puts her
hand down the garbage disposal
and turns it on.
It heals right away.
It was a little cool CGI.
But exploration is
really important.
This is a schematic of
Spiderman's spider-injecting,
spider-webbing stuff.
It's a little creepy,
the idea that it
comes out of his wrist.
But it was a schematic so he
could understand and explore.
What are the limits of this?
What are the parameters?
And in the film, he tries to see
how much he can get away
with without going on empty.
And this is what happens
when you don't explore.
This is not a DC Comic.
It says, "Superboy politely
apologizes for ripping some
dude's arm off." And he says,
"Aw man, I'm sorry.
That's totally my bad." Because
he didn't know the
limits of his strength.
This is a version in which he
did not explore the parameters
of his ability to
be different.
Also, there's control.
So one of the things that Luke
Skywalker does is learn to
control the ways that
he's different.
Buffy learns to control.
She has some super strength.
She learns to control that.
The other thing that happens
when you're different and you
acknowledge that is you
hopefully will decide to what
purpose should that
different-ness be put.
Superman, Clark Kent, struggles
with the gifts that
he's been given and how
should he use them.
NPR a while back had a
little radio poll.
If you could have a superpower,
what would it be?
And people would say, oh, X-ray
vision so I could see in
the girls' locker room,
or invisibility
and I'd rob a bank.
And I think at some point,
it gets kind of boring.
You know, how many girls' locker
rooms you want to look
in before you decide,
OK, now what?
And that's--
I mean, unless you're
a really early
pubescent teenager or something.
So purpose becomes
really important.
All the superheroes have this.
They have an ability.
How do they want to use it?
That's Hermione Granger,
who's definitely a
superhero in my book.
Tony Stark, Iron Man.
So the other thing superheroes
teach us is to band together
with like-minded folks.
So these are the X-Men,
Fantastic Four, DC
superheroes.
So this is Comic-Con,
banding together
with like-minded folks.
I don't know what these people
are, but they're clearly
banding together and they're
like-minded.
Banding together with
like-minded folks--
I mean, people are amazing.
There's so many different ways
we can be different.
Banding together with
like-minded folks.
Sometimes you are
the only one.
There is no one else like you.
And so in the middle, this is
Clark Kent from "Smallville."
And until his cousin appears,
there is no
other alien from Krypton.
So the best you can do is band
together with people who
accept the ways that you're
different and support you.
And those are his friends who
know that he's super.
This is Hell Boy
and Abe Sapien.
They are the only
ones on Earth.
But they band together with
people who support them.
So lesson one, acknowledge
the ways in
which you're different.
Until you claim it is a part
of yourself, you'll be
fighting against it.
Explore the boundaries of
your different-ness.
Learn to control it.
Think about how you
want to use it.
And then band together with
like-minded folks.
OK, so each of us is different
from everyone else.
But we're similar in
that we're all
different from each other.
That's the take-home message.
All right.
Adversity can be overcome.
Show of hands, how many people
here have experience--
I'm not going to ask any more
details than this--
experienced a traumatic stress
or significant adversity?
How many people have not?
You are really lucky.
And I hope that that lasts.
Most people will in their
lifetimes experience
significant adversity.
And a fun fact to
know and tell--
well, actually, first let me ask
you this other question.
So based on what you know of
the world, if someone has a
traumatic event, do you think
the likelihood is greater than
50% that they'll develop
post-traumatic stress disorder?
So if you agree that at least
50% of the people who
experience the trauma will get
PTSD, raise your hand.
Wow.
As a psychologist, I was in this
group until I read the
statistic that only 20% of
people who experience a trauma
go on to develop PTSD, which is
not what's portrayed in the
films and movies and books.
And so I just thought that
was really interesting.
And we know a lot at now about
what makes people more
vulnerable to developing it.
But I'm not talking
about PTSD today.
It's a little interesting
fact.
I want to talk about the 80% of
people, and the people who
have PTSD who moved
past it, which is
adversity can be overcome.
Many superheroes have
experienced significant adversity.
Just to name a few, we've got
Peter Parker, who initiated a
series of events that led to
the murder of his beloved
uncle and guardian Ben.
Prof.
Charles Xavier is a telepath and
was through the Holocaust
and experienced many peoples'
deaths in his mind.
Jean Grey is similar.
As a kid, she's a telepath and
experienced the death of her
friend in a car crash, depending
on which version.
Anakin Skywalker, where
do we start?
But he witnessed the torture and
then death of his mother,
then turned to the dark side.
Many of us, as I said, have
experienced some kind of
traumatic stressor or
significant adversity.
How are we doing on time?
OK.
I'm going to skip over the
specific kind of stressors and
adversity that people can have
because we know them.
But if we look at our
superheroes, what type did
they experience?
So this is Bruce Wayne
and witnessed the
murder of his parents.
And his own life
was in danger.
And then I'm going to show you
Tony stark from "Iron Man 1."
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
ROBIN ROSENBERG: And for those
of you in the know, in the
film, in contrast to the comics,
this was intended.
He was the target versus him
being an accidental target in
the comic, which actually makes
the story, I think, I
think a bit richer.
Intended personal violence is
the one that tends to leave
the biggest wake.
So if you were assaulted versus
in a natural disaster,
you're more likely to have a
bigger psychological effect.
People cope with adversity and
trauma by making meaning of
their events and aftermath.
And they understand it in a
larger framework about the
meaning of life.
So for most of us, before
adversity hits, we have a set
of global beliefs.
They include a belief in a just
world, which is that you
deserve what you get and you
get what you deserve.
It's a little circular,
a little childish, but
nonetheless, that we're
human, that it's
possible to trust others--
not all others, but
there are some
trustworthy people out there--
and that it's possible to be
effective in the world.
These beliefs drive
our global goals.
Whatever we're striving toward,
we're striving because
we believe that if we work hard,
we'll have an effect.
That if we work at a
relationship, you know
inherently the person
will be trustworthy.
We should try to find friends
and an intimate partner.
And that if we do good, we
should get good-- a belief in
a just world.
And then the beliefs and the
goals give us a sense that
life has purpose.
We're moving forward.
We have meaning.
Unfortunately, when you
experience significant
adversity or trauma, you say,
why did this happen?
Or if a loved one experienced
it, why did it happen to them?
Because it really challenges
a belief in a just world.
If I'm a basically good person
and something bad happens to
me, does it mean
I deserved it?
Because I get what I deserve
and I deserve what I get.
So it challenges the beliefs.
Oh, whoops, wrong button.
So, again, it challenges
belief in a just world.
If the trauma or adversity
involved another person who
was untrustworthy that we
trusted, it calls into
question our ability to evaluate
people and decide who
is trustworthy and who isn't.
And that's pretty scary.
And if we weren't able to
protect ourselves or the other
person that we care about, then
how can we be effective
in the world?
Because that's really the most
important thing is to really
protect yourself or
other people.
And these are pretty grim
existential questions that
people ask themselves after
adversity or a trauma.
So you question your global
beliefs which causes you to
question your goals.
Because why am I working
so hard if I
don't get what I deserve?
If I can't be effective,
what's the point?
And, in fact, life can feel
meaningless and purposeless.
There's a natural process.
People work through this.
Human beings are absolutely
amazing.
And part of how we work through
it and the process of
working through it is to develop
a fuller understanding
of why the negative events
happened, thinking through the
implications, which may be
changing the idea that you
don't get what you deserve--
you know, life isn't fair--
discovering possible silver
linings; recognizing that
other people are often worse
off, and putting the events in
a broader context.
So with resolution, people get
a heightened sense of self
where they're aware of
their vulnerability.
They appreciate life more.
And Nietzsche was right, a sense
of being stronger for
having survived.
They have an increased
connection to other people.
They're more expressive
emotionally, more disclosing
about what happened to them,
and, in general, an increased
empathy for others.
And they have an altered
philosophy of life.
And this is, I think, where
superheroes model for us.
They're more spiritual.
They live life more fully.
But they're also social
activists.
So I'm going to go through
the story of Batman.
Does anyone here not know
Batman's origin story?
Great.
Really quick, bottom panel's
his parents get killed.
This is the original 1939
comic, by the way.
It was his back story
developed in the
sixth Batman comic.
Bruce Wayne is incredibly
precocious in so many ways.
And so the important panel is
the last one, which is "Days
later, a curious and strange
scene takes place." For most
people, this is not days.
This may not even be
weeks or months.
But because he's Bruce Wayne,
it happens in days.
"And I swear by the spirit of
my parents to avenge their
deaths by spending the rest
of my life warring on all
criminals."
So he has gone through all of
this resolution process within
a few days of this terrible
thing happened to me.
It causes me to challenge
my beliefs and goals.
And I now have a new goal.
And it makes my life
feel meaningful.
He then proceeds to dedicate the
next decade or so of his
life to not just becoming a
scientist detective, but also
being at the peak
physical shape.
Is it fiction?
So psychologically, there's no
one who's really wealthy, who
has all these gadgets,
who's going around.
There are real-life superheroes
in New York, but I
don't think any of them
are like Bruce Wayne.
Psychologically, show of hands,
how many people think
it's fiction, doesn't
really ring true?
I've already got--
no, it's not.
So I don't know how many of
you people remembered Adam
Walsh, a young kid who was
kidnapped in the '80s and then
later found murdered.
His parents started the Adam
Walsh Foundation to help
families of missing kids.
His dad, David Walsh, went on
to be on "America's Most
Wanted."
So these are all variants
of the psychologically
true story of Batman.
So David Walsh dedicated the
rest of his life to helping
prevent what happened to him,
to his son, and after the
fact, helping people
if it did happen.
Jill Markussen was a
mortgage broker.
And in 2008, she lost her job
and almost lost her home.
And her community pitched in to
help her make her mortgage
so she didn't lose her home.
And when she got back on her
feet, she started Project
Flipmode to help other people
who are in danger of losing
their homes.
Willie Minniefield, his brother
needed a new kidney.
And minorities tend not to
donate organs at the same rate
as do whites.
And so, unfortunately, it didn't
work in time, but he
developed a Minority Organ
Donation Education Program to
encourage minority
organ donation.
Christy Nicholson, her husband
was killed in a
shootout with someone.
She, every year, does a huge
blood drive that have saved
hundreds of lives.
These are all real stories.
I mean, it's easy
to find these.
I mean, it's totally easy.
They're all over.
And these are the true
Batman stories.
So the writers of Batman, Bob
Kane and Bill Finger really
found something that was true.
And they translated it into
a superhero form.
But what they created was
real, psychologically.
Unfortunately, there's another
way to resolve this
discrepancy.
And that's to become
cynical and bitter.
And this is true.
And we, unfortunately, see
this in real life.
You have people who develop
global beliefs
that they're cynical.
They're greedy.
And they're hedonistic.
And they say, hey,
life is short.
I want to get mine
while I can.
We see this on Wall Street.
We see it in companies.
We see it in relationships.
And we see it in our villains.
So Magneto came through the
other side of the Holocaust
and had a very different
philosophy than Professor X.
The Joker--
whatever his back story
is, and we will
never know the truth--
he certainly came out the other
side with the sense of,
hey, live for today.
See how much sick fun
you can have.
And Two-Face, same thing.
Life is capricious.
Things are taken away from me.
I'm going to get mine.
So be a superhero.
Develop new global beliefs, new
global goals, new meaning
and purpose.
The costume counts.
I don't know about you, but when
I was a kid, my mother--
going shopping for clothes
was exquisite torture.
Because I wanted to dress
how I wanted to dress.
And she would say, no, it's
really important to make an
impression.
To this day, I will
not go shopping
with anyone for clothes.
But it had an impact on me.
Her words resonate in my head.
And for many, many years,
I didn't believe her.
And then I became
a psychologist.
And it was really hard to admit
that she was right.
What you wear affects you and
other people and the way they
respond to you.
And I'm going to walk you
through a little bit about the
science about this and what
we learn from superheroes.
Choose wisely.
I did not take her advice
for a very long time.
That's a costume.
These are all costumes.
Costumes are not just for
superheroes or Halloween.
We live in New York.
You know this.
Costumes are everywhere.
This is a costume.
Costumes.
CCer Certainly a costume.
So a costume communicates
something about ourselves,
what we wear.
It is a costume.
Everyone, we're all
wearing costumes
I'm wearing a costume.
You're wearing a costume.
So our dress communicates
a public self.
So this is Britney Spears
in her public
costume, such as it is.
And there's also what we want
to communicate about our
private selves.
And that's her private self.
How we dress also communicates
some aspect of a role that
we're playing.
And so we role play
with costumes.
In our daily wear, , again,
it's a costume.
We're communicating something
about ourselves.
In our evening or weekend wear,
we're communicating
something about ourselves.
And at special events,
we're communicating
something about ourselves.
So at weddings, at live action
role plays, we are
communicating something
about ourselves.
Superheroes are communicating
something about themselves
when they wear their costume.
We also communicate something
about ourselves and our
costume electronically with our
profiles and blogs, with
our avatars for those
who have an avatar.
And when we don these
costumes, we're also
communicating how we want to
influence how other people
view us and treat us.
Or we should be.
I mean, I didn't think I was,
but my mother was right.
So people do form impressions of
you based on what the glean
from your costume and
your appearance.
So, OK, what do you
think about her?
Real quick, just shout
out whatever.
What do you think of her?
What are you inferring
about her?
AUDIENCE: Preppy.
ROBIN ROSENBERG: Happy?
ROBIN ROSENBERG: Preppy.
OK, what made her look preppy?
AUDIENCE: The plaid.
ROBIN ROSENBERG: The plaid.
OK.
Anything else?
Any other thoughts?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
into manga.
ROBIN ROSENBERG: Into manga.
AUDIENCE: Because of her
costume, it looks manga-esque.
ROBIN ROSENBERG: Because of
her costume, it looks
manga-esque.
Any other thoughts?
OK.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] ironic.
ROBIN ROSENBERG:
Ironic because?
AUDIENCE: She's sort of going
over the top in the schoolgirl
sense and kind of back
around the other way.
Or at least that's one way
to think about it.
ROBIN ROSENBERG: OK.
Going over the top.
Good.
I gave this talk last night.
And I've never had this happen
before, but someone said they
thought she was a prostitute.
And another person thought
that she was a stripper.
Wow.
That had never entered
my mind.
Show of hands, actually, how
many think that's possible
from seeing this photograph?
Whoa.
So the point is we all make
inferences about each other.
Some of us make different
inferences than others.
But we all make inferences about
people based on how they
look and how they dress.
There also is a whole
other [INAUDIBLE].
Her posture is also such that
it's going to lead you to make
these-- it's not simply what
she's wearing, but it's her
non-verbals as well.
So it happens really quickly.
We just make these
evaluations.
How does this process work?
So there are two ways
we evaluate people
based on their costume.
One is a controlled,
deliberate,
and effortful process.
And we use it less frequently.
And I'm going to show you why.
Show of hands, how many people
have seen "Men in Black"?
For those of you who haven't,
in this scene that I'm going
to show you, Will Smith plays
a New York cop who doesn't
always play by the rules.
He's really good, but
he's fast and loose.
And he was invited to apply for
a job that was an elite
job, but he had no
idea what it was.
And he took all these paper and
pencil tests in the room
with people, high-ranking
generals from the military.
And all of that group that are
in the room applying for this
job and filling out forms are
now invited into a room where
they're going to
be given a gun.
And they're going to be asked
to shoot fake people, the
little cardboard kinds
of things.
So let's watch this.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[SIREN]
[BUZZER]
[GUNSHOTS]
-Edwards, what the
hell happened?
-Hesitated.
-May I ask why you felt little
Tiffany deserved to die?
-Well, she was only one that
actually seemed dangerous at
the time, sir.
-How'd you come to
that conclusion?
-Well, first I was going to pop
this guy hanging from the
streetlight.
And then I realized, you know,
he was just working out.
I mean, how would I feel if
somebody come running into the
gym, bust me in my ass while
I'm on the treadmill?
Then I saw this snarling
beast guy.
And I noticed he had a
tissue in his hand.
And I realized, you know, he's
not snarling, he's sneezing.
You know, ain't not
real threat there.
Then I saw a little Tiffany.
I'm thinking, you know,
eight-year-old white girl,
middle of the ghetto, bunch of
monsters, this time a night
with quantum physics books.
She about to start
some shit, Zed.
She's about eight years old.
Those books are way too
advanced for her.
If you ask me, I say she's
up to something.
And to be honest, I'd appreciate
it if you'd ease up
off my back about it.
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
ROBIN ROSENBERG: Why don't
we do this all the time?
It takes way too much effort
to sustain this.
We actually cannot do what Will
Smith did all the time.
Or if we did, we wouldn't be
able to function and do
anything else.
The cognitive load is so high.
We can do it sometimes
when we try, when it
counts, like he did.
But it's just not possible
to sustain.
So what do we do?
Instead, we use what's called
automatic processing.
And we take minimal information
and we classify
people according to the traits
that we infer about them.
So like the woman in the plaid
skirt, we're going to just see
plaid skirt, weird shirt,
pigeon-toed, and then whatever
you think-- stripper, ironic,
whatever your own personal
tastes are.
So we do this, again, through
social categorization, the
"us" versus "them" thing.
So we look at what
they're wearing.
And we say, oh, that's
like us.
That's like them, you know,
which them, which us.
And then when we
just assume it.
So there's a cognitive bias
that we know about in
psychology called the Halo
Effect, which is if an
individual has an important
attribute in one situation or
context, we infer that this
individual has additional
related attributes.
So villain or hero?
AUDIENCE: Hero.
ROBIN ROSENBERG: Hero.
OK, why?
AUDIENCE: The hair.
ROBIN ROSENBERG: The hair?
No, it's the Superman
little twisty thing.
No, that's true.
AUDIENCE: Square--
ROBIN ROSENBERG: What?
AUDIENCE: Square jaw.
ROBIN ROSENBERG: Square
jaw, yep.
OK.
Cleft chin, right?
Any other thoughts?
AUDIENCE: Smiling.
ROBIN ROSENBERG: Smiling, OK.
AUDIENCE: Nice cape.
ROBIN ROSENBERG:
Nice cape, OK.
AUDIENCE: Common pose, too.
ROBIN ROSENBERG: Common
pose, OK.
So all of this happened
instantly, before I even asked
you a question about it.
Once you saw it, you made all
of these assumptions.
So you looked at the cleft chin,
and you inferred other
qualities about it.
So in real life, we have
examples of this
in our daily life.
These are well-founded,
well-researched things.
So we think that good-looking
people are kinder,
which is not true.
I mean, a given person may or
may not be, but in general,
good looking people
aren't kinder.
And that we think
well-groomed job
applicants are more competent.
But, again, we are making all
these assumptions because it
helps us get by with less
cognitive effort.
OK, so there's a flip side of
this called the Devil Effect
or the Horn Effect.
And if someone has undesirable
attributes, then we infer that
the person has additional
related negative attributes.
So hero or villain?
AUDIENCE: Villain.
ROBIN ROSENBERG: Villain.
Why?
AUDIENCE: Dark colors.
ROBIN ROSENBERG: Say?
ROBIN ROSENBERG: Dark colors.
OK.
AUDIENCE: Scowling.
ROBIN ROSENBERG: Scowling,
frown, yep.
AUDIENCE: Small head compared
to the body.
ROBIN ROSENBERG: Small
head, right.
AUDIENCE: He's looking
down at us.
ROBIN ROSENBERG: He's
looking down at us.
Cool, OK.
AUDIENCE: His arms
are crossed.
ROBIN ROSENBERG: His
arms are crossed.
OK.
Cool.
Now, ironically, this stance is
very close to the Superman
stance, which is legs spread.
Its hands on hips.
We have seen Superman
in this pose.
So it's not simply the pose.
But you see how all of a sudden,
you saw this and you
instantly made a decision,
villain.
The metallic part
probably helped.
I assume it's metallic.
I'm not sure, but it's
shiny like metal.
And so we made all of
these attributes.
So I'm going to tell
you about a study--
people are already laughing.
So there was a study
that was done.
And you, as a participant, were
brought into the lab.
And you were shown photographs
of people.
Some of them were wearing
a plain T-shirt.
And some of them were
wearing what I'd
call an alcohol T-shirt.
It had Jack Daniels or
something on it.
In the photograph in the lab,
I had the same person.
Sometimes it was plain.
And I had photographs
of it being plain.
of it being alcohol.
So the people are the same.
It's just we both conditions,
if you will.
You were asked to rate people,
just like tell us what you
think about this person.
And some of those people wearing
a plain T-shirt and
some of them were wearing
an alcohol T-shirt.
Nothing else was different
except the alcohol words.
So what the participants said
is that the people in the
photographs who were
wearing an alcohol
T-shirt were rated as--
long list--
less honest, less independent,
less responsible, less
reliable, less religious, less
likely to be on time, less
likely to do well in school.
They were more likely to smoke,
to be a party animal,
drink or swear, and
be risk-taker.
All of this inferred
from alcohol words.
I think it's probably true.
I mean, I know I should know
better, but I would make the
same assumptions.
But we don't know where the
person got the T-shirt.
It was a gift, it was--
I mean, It's just interesting
how all of this
negative stuff came out.
So social categorization
reduces the
effort we have to expend.
We don't have to think if the
guy in the cape was a bad guy.
We just immediately make
these assumptions.
But it makes us more likely
to make biased judgments.
So people categorize us
based on how we dress.
And then they treat
us accordingly.
My mother was right.
Now the interesting thing is
that the way they treat us can
elicit certain behaviors
from us.
And my mother didn't quite
tell me this part.
Although I think she have
intuited because she's a good
lay psychologist.
There was a study done.
There was another study.
You're brought into the lab.
You are a woman.
And you're told you're going
to have a telephone
conversation with another
participant in the study.
And so you go into this
cubicle, and you'll
speak to him there.
And whatever they told me,
to talk about whatever.
If you are a guy and you came
into the lab, you were shown a
photograph.
And you were told this is the
woman you're going to talk to.
Come into this cubicle.
Now it turns out, half the guys
were shown a photograph
of an attractive woman.
And half the guys were shown
a photograph of an
unattractive woman.
And these were objectively
rated beforehand.
People rated the photographs
of who is
attractive and who wasn't.
These photographs had nothing to
do with the actual woman in
the cubicle waiting to
talk to the guy.
So just again to reiterate the
set-up, they're told they're
going to talk to a woman who's
either attractive or
unattractive.
So that's the panel
on the left.
In the middle panel, they
have their conversation.
They're separately
tape-recorded.
They leave the lab.
They're done.
In the lab, a rater who works
for the professor is listening
to the women's part of the
conversation only.
And they are rating her tone
of voice for warmth and
friendliness.
That's their job.
And then they rate them.
And then they look back and see
did the guys think that
these were attractive women
or unattractive women.
And it turns out that the women
who were rated as warm
and friendly were the women
where the guy thought that she
was going to be attractive.
So what happened is the guy
thinks, I'm going to talk to
someone who's attractive.
And he somehow interacts with
her in a way that elicits this
warmth and friendliness
from her.
And he didn't even see her.
It was just on the
phone, something
in his tone of voice--
they, it was a lot of guys,
it wasn't just one guy.
Something elicited from her
behavior that made her conform
to how he assumed she was.
It becomes a self-fulfilling
prophecy where the way you
dress causes people to treat
you accordingly.
And how they treat you, then,
elicits that behavior from
you, whether you
want to or not.
It's all unconscious.
This happens like in the
ether between people.
It elicits the behavior.
And it becomes a self-fulfilling
prophecy.
So people will make inferences
about you based on your
appearance.
And most of the time, they
will not be Will Smith.
They will not make that
extra effort and go
beyond a snap judgment.
So their judgments affect their
behavior, which affects
your behavior and thoughts
and feelings without your
knowing about it.
And it becomes a self-fulfilling
prophecy.
So what costume do
you want to wear?
You should ask yourself what
part of yourself do you want
to hide or express?
What role do you want to play?
What snap judgments do you want
other people to make of
you because they will?
Are you willing to have
these become a
self-fulfilling prophecy?
And I think we don't--
I have time for questions,
so I'll just
skip over this lesson.
Questions, thoughts, ideas?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: So I actually have
a question and a comment.
So I'll start with the
comment about the
experiment with the shirts.
ROBIN ROSENBERG: OK.
One second.
Is there a mic they're
supposed to go to?
Oh, I'm sorry, if you have a
question, just go to a mic.
Sorry, I forgot about that.
AUDIENCE: So the comment is
about the experiment with the
shirts with the Jack Daniels.
So as you were describing
that, I was thinking to
myself, well, OK, but what--
I'll just speak for myself,
but I think
this is fairly typical.
What happens is a lot of times
with things like that is
there's a thing that goes on in
your mind where you say--
not particularly about the Jack
Daniels shirt, that's
fairly innocuous--
but somebody wears a particular
shirt and so
immediately the place you go
to is, well, you made a
conscious choice to wear
that shirt, right?
So the wearer is trying to
transmit something about
themselves.
Whether that's right or wrong,
it doesn't matter.
But that's sort of what goes
on in your head as the
observer is, well, you chose
to wear that shirt.
You're trying to send out
some kind of signal.
ROBIN ROSENBERG: Right.
AUDIENCE: Which could
be totally wrong.
The other thing is
about superheros.
So I'm the father of two boys
who are both adults now.
But the one thing that struck
me-- and I know, I watched, I
read comic books when
I was a kid.
And I'm old enough that I
remember the George Reeves
Superman, although
it was in reruns.
I'm not quite that old.
But one thing that struck me
with both of my sons was how
early the hook sank
about superheroes.
I mean, I can remember my older
son being like 18 months
old, taking his baby blanket
and asking us to wrap it
around his neck as a cape.
In fact, at this point, I wish
they'd wean themselves from
that stuff, but maybe
by 40 they will.
ROBIN ROSENBERG: Or not.
AUDIENCE: But yeah, maybe not.
But one thing that struck
me was there's got to be
something deeper going
on there, right?
There's something in their
very, very young minds.
ROBIN ROSENBERG: Primal.
AUDIENCE: There's something
that's resonating in terms of
what they desire to be.
Or I'm not sure exactly what
it is, but that the
hook sinks so early.
I mean, obviously there's
a lot more.
If all your friends are
surrounding you and they're
all carrying Spiderman lunch
boxes, and there's a lot more
of that stuff, certainly,
than when I was younger.
But I'm wondering if there's
something deeper than that,
that's it's not just media
pressure, that there's some
hook that sets in very early.
ROBIN ROSENBERG: Absolutely.
And actually the book that's
not on sale there, "Our
Superheroes, Ourselves"
addresses
some of this question.
It's essays by psychologists
talking about our relationship
with superheroes and the ways in
which we're similar to and
different from superheroes.
So before there were
superheros, it
was cowboys and Indians.
It was probably Sampson
versus Delilah.
I mean, throughout history
kids play.
And they play about characters
that they know, Bible figures.
If they're exposed to
superheroes, it's superheroes.
Kids really want moral clarity
about right and wrong.
And I think part of what
superhero stories offer, aside
from the violent part, is the
kid superhero stories offer
moral clarity.
And they also show that
sometimes doing the right
thing is hard, which is a lesson
that we actually want
adults to remember.
So being a whistle-blower is
a great example that's a
superhero tale without
the power.
So kids are just gravitated
toward moral
clarity and also power.
I mean, kids are unbelievably
powerless in the world.
They have so little control
over anything.
And the idea of being this
superhero and having all of
these powers and being
able to do all
these things is amazing.
And then the other piece, just
to address that, is the kids
are easily self-hypnotizable.
In the Western world, most
of us lose our ability to
hypnotize ourselves.
But kids are amazing at it.
That's their fantasy play.
They are there.
And so superhero stories, when
they imagine them, it is
incredibly vivid as
if it's real.
And so when they put on a cape
and imagine themselves flying,
they are self-hypnotized.
I mean, they're not going
to jump out a window or
anything like that.
Or, unfortunately, occasionally
that happens if
there aren't screens
on the window.
But it's very vivid and powerful
for them in a way
that dream life can be this
amazing release and experience
that when they imagine being
a superhero, it taps into
something very primal.
Before it was superheroes,
it was something else.
But I think that
urge is there.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Hi.
So you talked about the
inferences that we
automatically make based
on the visual
cues that we observe.
And I understand that as an
empirical observation.
You also give the advice that,
be careful what you wear.
ROBIN ROSENBERG: Yes.
AUDIENCE: I felt like that was
a little insufficient if you
don't talk about the
conditioning that is done on
society and why those inferences
are actually made.
Because there's nothing about
looking at a character from
below or looking at a character
from above that is
any correlation to good or bad,
negative or positive.
So I was hoping you could
talk a little bit about
re-conditioning.
ROBIN ROSENBERG: Sure.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
ROBIN ROSENBERG: So all
of us have our own
unique learning history.
Some of it is shared.
If we watch the same films and
movies and TVs, or read the
same books, and are exposed to
things, then part of our
learning history is shared.
And part of it is unique to our
family and our community.
And then our own personal,
unique
history that no one shares.
And all of those go into the
assumptions and inferences
that you make about people.
So for instance, I have two
sons who work at Google.
So I feel like I can say this.
So if you grow up in a
family where people
don't iron their shirts.
Your kids will have certain
assumptions that are going to
be different about people who
wear non-ironed shirts, who
wear rumpled shirts, than
someone who grows up in a
family where the underwear
was ironed.
And so that will influence what
you think when you see
someone in a rumpled shirt.
You can absolutely overwrite
what you've
learned with new learning.
And so if instead of working
at Google, you now end up
working on Wall Street, and you
are told in no uncertain
terms that you need to have
a suit and tie every day.
And it needs to be really
expensive suit.
And you should definitely
have ironed shirts.
You will have new learning.
And you will learn whatever the
culture there wants you to
learn about ironed shirts,
about what it means.
So humans are great learners,
some of the time.
And so in this context, you
would learn new things.
If a film came out that shot
the superhero the other way
around and the villain from
above, and that was the new
point-of-view style, then we
would just unlearn that.
This new learning would
overwrite the old learning.
Did that answer your question?
AUDIENCE: That wasn't
my question.
ROBIN ROSENBERG: No, did that
answer your question?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
ROBIN ROSENBERG:
OK, not really?
AUDIENCE: So I totally
understand the conditioning of
inferences.
But what I was getting at
is I think they are very
subjective.
And they sometimes result in
undesirable effects against
other people.
So I think there has to be an
effort to recondition those
factors that cause
the inferences so
that they, I guess--
ROBIN ROSENBERG: Ah, OK.
Right.
So the effort to recondition
more accurately.
The problem is it's like
the Will Smith dilemma.
We can't do that all the time.
We just can't function in the
world and simultaneously be
reconditioning ourselves and
checking whether the
assumptions we're making about
people, is that true.
We can do it some of the
time, when it counts.
When we care, we can do it.
When I'm meeting someone for the
first time and I know if
I'm looking, and I say, oh,
this person is X, Y, and Z
based on how they look.
I can take the time to get
to know that person.
I can make a decision to take
the time to get to know the
person to see, are my hypotheses
about them correct?
But we can't do that
all the time.
It's just a huge amount
of effort.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Question about your
specific choice of hero
exemplar for lesson two,
specifically Batman as an
example of someone who is
psychologically well adjusted
to psychological shock.
ROBIN ROSENBERG: OK.
Let's put down the
gauntlets here.
OK, go ahead.
AUDIENCE: I think especially in
the post-Alan Moore, post
'80s comic hero era, we have
started looking at superheroes
who are simply not
psychologically well put together.
And Batman, the vigilante who
has serious issues in current
generation post-rebirth
DC comics, why?
There are--
ROBIN ROSENBERG: [INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: --any number of people
who are better put--
even Cyclops as fewer issues
than Batman who is
fundamentally a broken person.
ROBIN ROSENBERG: OK, so I
don't agree with you.
I wrote a book called "Whats
the Matter with Batman?"
AUDIENCE: I will
be buying that.
ROBIN ROSENBERG: I will
send you a copy.
Come afterwards.
And I kind of go through the
likely diagnoses for him.
And part of where I come out is
that everyone has issues.
You cannot live in this world
and not have issues.
His issues are obvious,
granted.
But I don't think that he's
really screwed up.
I think that this is a man who
is a serious guy, perhaps by
temperament, we don't know.
I mean, it's hard to say what
he was like before.
I mean, I think "Batman
Begins" film is really
interesting in how it portrayed
him how he was before.
And that's really an
interesting take.
But he's a serious guy.
I don't think being serious
means your screwed up.
It just means you're serious.
He has issues with
relationships.
Who doesn't?
I mean, put aside the 50%
divorce rate, how many
relationships don't work?
I mean most intimate
relationships we have in life
don't work out.
I'm not going to say he's
screwed up for that reason.
Then all of us would
be screwed up.
If you go down the list
of the ways--
he's serious, and he's
a dedicated guy.
It's like to say that Navy SEALs
would be screwed up, or
thoracic surgeons who spend--I
don't know--
20 years in training and are on
call all the time and often
have difficult marriages and
lives because they're on call
all the time and it's
incredibly--
you have to have a certain
personality to get to be a
thoracic surgeon, to get
to the end stage.
It's sort of an occupational
hazard.
Being a cop changes people.
Any discipline, any
occupation changes
people in certain ways.
So I would take issue
with you about that.
And I was intentional.
AUDIENCE: I appreciate that.
ROBIN ROSENBERG: OK.
But give me your address.
I'll send you a copy
of the book.
Any other questions?
No more people want
to take on Batman?
I'm ready.
I'm prepared.
Anything else?
Oh, yeah?
AUDIENCE: It's sort of a
follow-up to the last question.
Then where did the dark
age come from?
I mean we had in the '30s and
the '40s, we had the golden
age, which was these really
naive characters, and the '50s
in the '60s.
In the '60s and '70s, they got
a little more serious.
And then with "Watchmen" and
"The Dark Knight Returns," all
of a sudden, they were all, if
not broken, then a whole lot
less pure and a whole lot
harder to root for.
Some of that, I think, just came
from the changes in how
comic books got sold
in the 1980s.
But that was a long time ago.
And we had a dark Superman
movie this
year, or so I've told.
Where does the attraction with
dark superheroes come from?
I mean, light superheros,
I understand.
Have we grown up?
ROBIN ROSENBERG: I actually
think part of it is that we
have grown up.
So those of us who read comics
as kids, or Saturday morning
cartoons, we grew up.
And those simple moral tales
that appealed to us as kids do
not appeal to us now.
They were simplistic.
And they are not consistent with
our nuanced experience of
the world where morality is
often relative and it depends
on context.
And so I think that Alan Moore
unleashed the pent-up desire
for more sophisticated
stories.
And then I think with that, we
started wondering, so what
would it be like to
be a superhero?
What would it be like
to be Batman?
Or Superman is actually a harder
one, but what would it
be to live day in, day
out as a superhero?
And we want to see
our characters
suffer a little bit.
So if it gets darker, it's
because they get real.
AUDIENCE: But why did our
generation change?
Because my mom bought "Action"
number one and regretted the
rest of her life
not keeping it.
So she grew up on the really
simplistic superheros.
And then she grew up.
Did she just ignore all the
comic book superheroes?
Or did something happen with
this generation that wanted
darker superheros that didn't
happen with the previous
generation that was happy to
have the more pure ones?
ROBIN ROSENBERG: I think
two things happened.
One is realism in general.
Psychological realism was
just in all other
genres, so why no.
I mean, even in spaghetti
Westerns, it started happening.
Clint Eastwood became
a three-dimensional
character in his films.
So I think it was in the
zeitgeist at the time.
And I also think that for your
mom, maybe you went with your
mom to see the first Chris
Reeves' "Superman" film?
Maybe it was a family
affair, maybe not.
AUDIENCE: She watched "Star
Trek" with me, which fits me a
little bit better.
ROBIN ROSENBERG: OK, she
watched "Star Trek."
AUDIENCE: Almost superheroes.
ROBIN ROSENBERG: Right.
But I think we also delayed
having kids.
And so we were happy to have
adult-oriented superhero stories.
Where when people had
kids sooner, it
was a family affair.
Reading comics together,
talking about and
watching the TV shows.
And so I think it was a more
private experience.
And that's what was offered.
And honestly, I think we
just all became more
psychologically sophisticated
and wanted our
heroes to be, too.
AUDIENCE: OK, thank you.
ROBIN ROSENBERG: A great
question, though.
And any other questions?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Isn't it the case of
the early Batman was a lot
more violent than later?
And it certainly was the case
the comics in the early '50s
were a lot more violent
than they were
before the comic code.
ROBIN ROSENBERG: Yes.
AUDIENCE: And before the
"Watchmen," there was Frank
Miller turning daredevil into
somebody who drops somebody to
break all the bones
in his body.
I mean, it didn't happen
immediately.
ROBIN ROSENBERG: Right.
Every decade is a little
bit different.
And there's a history, the
pendulum swings to and from.
And the original Batman
was really dark.
And so many people view the
Christopher Nolan films as a
return to his roots.
It was very dark for its time.
So, right, it depends
on which era.
Michael Uslan, who was the
executive producer of all of
the recent Batman films since
1989 and has thought deeply
about Batman says that-- he
extends it beyond Batman--
but whenever you were first
exposed to a superhero,
whatever version that was it
its moment in time, that's
your template of the
real superhero.
And everything else is sort
of a deviation from that.
It's like an imprinting.
And I think there is
something to that.
Yeah.
Any other questions?
OK.
Thanks.
Great questions.
[APPLAUSE]
ROBIN ROSENBERG: Thank you.